Traduttore: Chiara Bertino
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Mi occupo di acqua dal 2008,
dal giorno in cui mia sorella
mi regala un libro bellissimo
e che mi cambia la vita:
"Le guerre dell'acqua" di Vandana Shiva.
Oggi sono qui per parlarvi
della relazione tra acqua e cibo.
Una relazione complessa, problematica,
troppo spesso sottovalutata.
Prima però devo fare un passo indietro.
Dal 1950 siamo entrati nell'Antropocene,
l'era geologica caratterizzata
dalla trasformazione
e dall'intervento massiccio
dell'uomo sul pianeta,
che lo sta alterando
a livello territoriale,
atmosferico e idrologico,
profondamente.
Alcuni dei cambiamenti in atto
nell'Antropocene sono irreversibili.
Primo tra tutti il cambiamento climatico,
che non è solo un fenomeno ambientale,
ma che ha implicazioni molto forti
sociali, politiche ed economiche.
Il cambiamento climatico è stato collegato
all'insorgere di conflitti,
alle emigrazioni di intere popolazioni
e anche a fenomeni come le acquisizioni
di terra su larga scala.
Un fenomeno che quando avviene
in negazione del diritto umano
prende il nome di "land grabbing",
cioè di accaparramento di terra.
Il pianeta è letteralmente
ricoperto di acqua,
ma solo lo 0,001% di quest'acqua
che ricopre il pianeta
è disponibile per l'uso umano.
Il resto, infatti, è acqua salata,
oppure si trova allo stato solido
o non è direttamente accessibile.
L'acqua, inoltre, è distribuita
sul pianeta in maniera diseguale.
Troviamo, infatti, che quasi il 70%
delle riserve di acqua dolce
sono concentrate
in soli 13 paesi del mondo.
I problemi idrici hanno radici diverse.
Da una parte troviamo un tipo di scarsità
che ha la sua radice
nella mancanza di acqua in un territorio.
Questo tipo di scarsità
colpisce 1 persona su 5 sul pianeta
e appunto si verifica quando
la quantità di acqua in un'area
non riesce a soddisfare i bisogni
della popolazione che la abitano.
Generalmente, questo tipo di scarsità
si trova in paesi
che sono largamente dipendenti
dalle importazioni di cibo.
E tra poco scopriremo perché.
C'è un altro tipo di scarsità,
un tipo di scarsità
molto più preoccupante della precedente,
perché avviene in contesti di povertà
e colpisce 1 persona su 4 sul pianeta.
Questo tipo di scarsità è radicata
nelle condizioni sociali, economiche
e istituzionali che precludono l'accesso
all'acqua a parte della popolazione.
Perché è preoccupante?
Perché non avere accesso all'acqua,
il diritto all'acqua negato,
un diritto che dovrebbe essere,
che è un diritto umano,
significa non poter uscire
dalla trappola della povertà.
Per questo deve preoccuparci
ancora di più.
L'agricoltura è il cuore del problema,
l'elefante nella stanza,
questo perché il 70%
dell'acqua dolce che preleviamo
è dedicata alla produzione di cibo
e di beni agricoli, in generale.
Tale percentuale sale molto
in paesi aridi o semi aridi,
fino ad arrivare ad oltre il 90%.
L'agricoltura è inoltre
un settore importante
anche dal punto di vista
dell'impatto delle emissioni.
Infatti è il secondo settore che
emette più gas serra nell'atmosfera.
Quindi, è proprio qui che dobbiamo
andare ad analizzare e capire il problema,
ma poiché l'agricoltura ci nutre, è qui
che dobbiamo anche cercare le soluzioni.
Negli ultimi 100 anni la popolazione
è cresciuta in modo esponenziale,
ma ancora di più è cresciuto
il consumo di acqua,
a un tasso che è pari a più del doppio di
quello della crescita della popolazione.
Questo perché abbiamo modificato
profondamente il modo in cui viviamo,
in particolare abbiamo modificato
il nostro consumo di cibo.
E al modificare le nostre
abitudini alimentari, la nostra dieta,
abbiamo allargato la nostra
impronta idrica pro capite.
A livello individuale abbiamo bisogno
di circa 2 litri per dissetarci di acqua,
tra i 30 e i 50 litri per l'uso domestico,
ma ogni giorno ognuno di noi ha bisogno di
almeno 2000 litri di acqua per mangiare.
Questo perché l'acqua è un input
di produzione fondamentale,
nella produzione di cibo,
in tutte le fasi della filiera,
in particolare nella prima,
la fase sul campo: la coltivazione.
È questa l'intuizione
che ha avuto Tony Allan,
professore del King's College
e il mio supervisor di dottorato,
nel chiamare quest'acqua "acqua virtuale".
Perché è un'acqua non più visibile
all'interno del cibo,
ma che effettivamente
è stata utilizzata per produrlo.
A tipi di alimenti diversi corrispondono
impronte idriche diverse.
Serve circa 1 metro cubo d'acqua
per produrre 1000 calorie vegetali
e ne servono circa 5 metri cubi
per produrre 1000 calorie animali.
Però fermarci a guardare l'ampiezza
dell'impronta idrica non è abbastanza,
perché ciò che determina
la sostenibilità di un prodotto
non è soltanto il volume di acqua
contenuto in modo virtuale al suo interno,
ma è il rispetto
della vocazione di un territorio,
il rispetto
delle pratiche agricole sostenibili,
il contesto in cui è avvenuto.
È questo che va a determinare
la sostenibilità o meno
del prodotto che portiamo
sulle nostre tavole.
Quello che vedete era il lago di Aral.
Un lago tra Kazakistan e Uzbekistan
che negli ultimi trent'anni
abbiamo quasi interamente prosciugato
per produrre riso e cotone
destinati all'export.
Questo lago ha raddoppiato
la sua concentrazione salina,
negli ultimi trent'anni,
e diminuito il volume
delle sue acque di circa 15 metri.
Il commercio... il commercio agricolo,
il commercio di cibo, in particolare,
stabilisce una relazione tra me che mangio
e il paese in cui ha avuto luogo
la produzione agricola.
Questo commercio,
questo legame invisibile,
mi rende anche vulnerabile a crisi idriche
che colpiscono paesi in apparenza lontani,
ma che possono andare a influenzare
il mio approvvigionamento di cibo,
quindi la mia capacità di mangiare
determinati tipi di alimenti.
Ad esempio, in Europa il 40%
della nostra impronta idrica alimentare
proviene da paesi extraeuropei,
e alcuni sono estremamente vulnerabili
dal punto di vista idrico,
mettendo a repentaglio intere filiere,
ad esempio quelle di riso, cotone o soia.
Di fronte a questo scenario,
come si prospetta il futuro?
La risposta che mi sono data è:
se noi non cambiamo,
le cose non cambieranno,
anzi peggioreranno.
Perché tra trent'anni saremo
in 10 miliardi su questo pianeta.
8 persone su 10 vivranno in città.
Vivere in città significa distaccarsi
progressivamente dal cibo,
vivere una sorta di alienazione
da chi lo ha prodotto,
da come è stato prodotto,
dalla stagionalità,
dalla vocazione di un territorio.
Perché abbiamo a disposizione tutto
in qualsiasi momento dell'anno.
È proprio da qui che dobbiamo ripartire,
io credo, per costruire un futuro diverso.
Prima di tutto, è importante
ripensare l'agricoltura.
L'agricoltura del futuro deve
produrre meglio,
quindi con più efficienza,
e con meno, con meno risorse.
È importante dal punto di vista politico
dare gli strumenti,
investire negli agricoltori,
nella loro formazione,
nel dargli accesso alle tecnologie,
perché effettivamente possano
aiutarci a transitare verso modalità
di produzione più sostenibili.
In particolare i piccoli agricoltori,
da cui dipende
la nostra sicurezza alimentare.
I politici hanno anche il dovere
di smettere di sussidiare
produzioni agricole dannose per l'ambiente
e che spesso non vanno neanche
nella direzione
degli obiettivi di salute pubblica.
E noi siamo quello che mangiamo.
Quindi è importante che loro
prendano questo impegno.
A chi fa ricerca, l'impegno non solo
di continuare a lavorare
per migliorare la conoscenza,
ma anche di favorire la comprensione,
cercando di non aver paura
di occasioni belle ed emozionanti
come quella di oggi.
Favorendo quindi la comprensione
delle persone, delle persone che come
cittadini e come consumatori di cibo,
hanno un grandissimo potere:
il potere di influenzare chi produce cibo,
chiedendo tracciabilità e trasparenza,
chiedendo responsabilità
sociale e ambientale.
Prima di lasciarvi,
voglio dirvi un'ultima cosa.
C'è una teoria che ipotizza
che tra due persone,
in qualsiasi punto del pianeta,
esista una catena
di non più di sei intermediari.
Quello che vi chiedo è di condividere
le idee che avete ascoltato oggi
e di chiedere alla vostra rete
di fare altrettanto, perché in questo modo
mi avrete aiutato a trasformare
la conoscenza in consapevolezza,
che credo sia l'arma di costruzione
di massa più potente che abbiamo. Grazie.
(Applausi)